hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from the first guwahati
international open grand master
tournament it's from round five and it
was suggested by a lot of you uh for
good reasons and to explain the title a
little bit uh well some two years ago in
2019 i made a video where i referred to
kantoli ratnakaran as the indian town
and some four years ago uh i think it
was in 2017. i made a video on adham
fawzi and his brilliant play
saying that he is well
he he definitely plays like the egyptian
tall and here we have a game from 2022
where the two face off against each
other and you can only imagine that the
game is extremely interesting as both of
them have a very very unique style so uh
that being said uh we've explained the
title a little bit let's check out the
game
uh so uh ratnakaran has the y piece and
he opens with e4
we have c5 by fawzi going for the
sicilian defense knight to f3 knight to
the c6 and bishop to b5 going for the
niche medina rossolimo attack we have g6
now the infinite variation uh
one of carlson's favorite um uh opening
strategies with castles and bishop to g7
rook to e1 now and e5 putting the pawn
nicely in the center as even if the
bishop captures the knight here the
bishop on g7 will be nicely defending
the e5 pawn so here bishop captures d
captures on c6 and now h3 so black has a
double c pawn but if you've
ever encountered this opening you know
that it's not really a weakness as
white will have some problems executing
d4 at any time so here we have knight to
e7 d3 and now black just castles we have
bishop to e3 attacking the pawn here and
b6 so this is all very standard stuff
this position has been reached
several times already we have a4 now and
black strikes with a5 now a5 is not
really necessary
uh but uh neither is neither is a4 or
better yet
a5 is necessary but a4 wasn't because
the black wasn't really threatening to
go b5 usually you play a4 with white to
stop b5 but here this pawn is kind of
stuck here guarding the c5 pawn so maybe
you don't have to play a4 but a5 is very
much
needed as now white will have problems
executing both b4 and d4 and these are
kind of the breakthroughs you want to uh
you want to have with white and there is
a game in the database where knight a3
was played but here we have knight b to
d2 and it is now as of movie 11 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
how the game continues uh opens with uh
starts with a queen to c7
develops the queen now the bishop has to
be developed and the rooks will be
connected and now queen to b1 now
preparing ideas like c3 and b4 so you
have to get this breakthrough in with h6
by black and now rook to a3 so as you
can imagine the position might open up
and then this rook will have a lot to do
on the third rank maybe shifted in the
center of the board maybe shifted all
the way to the king side to help out
with the attack and as the bishop is
still on g7 you do not want it on a1
uh so bishop to e6 and now c3 preparing
d4 but also b4
and the black says all right i'm not
waiting for that let's start with f5 uh
putting pressure on white center we have
e captures on f5 and now bishop captures
an f5
if you wanted to make the game a little
bit more interesting maybe g captures an
f5 is also an option but nothing wrong
with bishop captures on f5 and also the
queen is on b1 so it makes sense uh here
we have g4 chasing the bishop away
bishop to e6 and now striking in the
center with the d4 and now c captures on
d4 uh is uh
is probably the the way you want to play
this but it's uh kind of tricky because
the bishop on e6 is undefended you have
a rook on e1 and if the position opens
up could be a problem for black so
instead falsely opens uh starts with uh
key captures on d4 but now we have c
characters on d4 and here
white misses a great uh trick because
bishop captures an h6 looks to be a way
to completely shatter black's defenses
after let's say bishop captures we're
going to capture on e6 and it doesn't
look like a position you want to be
playing but um okay it's it's uh really
an open position so
a lot could still happen so instead we
have c captures on d4 but now bishop to
d5 and now you no longer have the same
ideas
as the the bishop is not a liability on
e6 rather you are threatening to win a
piece here but here we have d captures
on c5 and now what's the what's the
point of this why are you hanging a
knight on f3 uh well uh the point is if
bishop captures on f3 as it was played
in the game here we have c captures on
b6 and then
maybe instead of capturing an f3 we
could play something like b5 but it
seems like such a such a great move why
not just grab the piece and allow white
this little uh
you know opportunity to create a pass
pawn it's probably probably not not
going to be all that all that much so
instead the bishop captures an f3 like
we've shown c captures on b6 and also uh
here for those of you who are maybe just
starting your chess journey whenever
your opponent captures a piece don't
capture back automatically look uh for
an in-between move here you can see that
there is a move of a greater importance
at that and that is c captures on v6 as
this comes with an attack on the queen
so we usually say this move comes with
tempo and first black has to deal with
this and only then will we continue to
what we were planning to do so queen to
d7 and now
uh what do you play here well white
really wants to play bishop to c5 you
already have a rook on e1 you want to
attack that knight one more time but you
also don't want your knights to hang on
d2 so here uh
ratnakan plays a really really brilliant
move and that is b7
you could also play rook to d3 but b7 is
just in his style and now everything uh
completely explodes so the idea is if
the pawn on b7 is captured then it's
kind of uh well we can just show it
queen captures on b7 the idea is bishop
to c5 now the knight is hanging and once
we deal with this end we've already
grabbed the piece so we don't want to be
too greedy we're going to play bishop to
d5 this is an excellent square for our
bishop rook captures on e7 attacks the
queen queen captures on bq and now let's
say rook captures and g7 queen captures
on g7 and bishop captures on f8 so this
is all very nicely done and after rook
captures you get this position where the
material is completely equal uh the
difference is it's a bishop against the
knight and black spawn structure is uh
somewhat loose white's pawn structure is
also somewhat loose but white at least
has three pawns in front of the king
black has only two but still this bishop
controls all of these squares could be
very unpleasant
all in all with a perfect play should be
something uh
something like a draw let's say rookie
three the game continues and uh both
players will have chances uh but after
b7 we have rook eight to b8 now fawzi
once uh wants everything he is not
interested in drawing this game and now
you could go for knight captures on f3
and that's perfectly fine no one would
blame you if you played this uh we can
even show it rook captures on f3 and now
bishop to a7 attacks the rook attacks
the rook now comes rook captures on b7
rook captures on a3 rook captures on a7
and we get this position where you can
see that
it's super super complicated but black
is still up a piece but
it's not easy to
uh it's definitely not easy to play this
well of course we're still gonna capture
with captures and i have seven rook
captures on a7 and now you will get this
position where black will really have
two pieces for a rook
and uh well it's a it's a very rich
position so this is uh definitely in the
position but instead after rook a to b8
we have bishop to c5 but nakano
definitely wants more this game and now
uh what is the plan here he already gave
up a piece now he's offering the knight
on d2 uh let's see what happens the
queen captures on the e2 uh we have rook
captures on e7 and now just a bishop
back to d5 so now after all is said and
done black is just up a piece uh and uh
well uh
white has a
a pass pawn here on b7 that's nicely
defended by the rook on e7 and here
could you capture on g6 if you could
capture here that's gonna be great for
you the problem is if you leave the back
rank then we play queen d1 check and
look at this you are definitely not
surviving this let's say king h2 queen
h1 check king g3 rook to f3 with check
we forced a rook trade and now after
captures and captures king h4 we're
gonna offer a queen trade here and now
this end game will be completely winning
for us once the queens get off the board
so instead we have rook to d3 now
attacking the queen uh queen to f4 and
now only now do we execute b4 now we're
saying we want you to play a captures on
b4 and then we get a5 a6 a7 and we win
the game but it's not it's not that
simple uh black plays rook to f7 now
comes rook captures on d5 this is played
with with absolute precision uh make no
mistake black is still winning here but
he has to also play with with surgical
precision here
and now the problem is if you play rook
captures on e7 then bishop d6 and you no
longer have anything with black so
instead we have c captures on d5 you
have to play white's game uh b captures
on a5 now and now you have to be very
careful if a6 a7 happens that's just it
so here rook captures on e7 uh we're up
material so eliminating more stuff from
the board definitely makes sense bishop
captures on e7
uh and now bishop to d4 going after that
f2 pawn uh here fox just says you've got
nothing uh how how do you want to
to end this uh capturing and g6 doesn't
really do anything if you capture here i
just play king h8 that's game uh there's
no way to to follow up here so instead
after bishop to d4 we have bishop to h4
guarding the f2 pawn
and now there are several ways to play
this the the absolute best one for black
is just king h7 you don't have to worry
about g6 anymore and now you continue
the game everything is still
working in your favor and uh you just
win if something like a6 happens we play
rook to f8 we simply add more pressure
to f2 and you will not be able to
survive this with white however in the
game uh the only move that should not
have been played was split and that is
g5
and it kind of makes sense because we
already discussed queen to g6 many times
and it never really works but here uh
it's uh it's a move that actually works
now comes queen to g6 and of course uh
g5 uh looks great because if you move
the bishop just queen captures the f1 is
pinned it's an instant win for black
however here we have queen to g6 with
check
and now you have to play king to f8 and
then comes queen captures on h6 with
checking f7 the game continues with
black still being slightly better
however after queen to g6 we have bishop
to g7 blocking check and now the game is
completely winning for white
but you have to play it very precisely
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this winning idea while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations uh on uh you know
getting away from all the action and
concentrating on what really matters uh
or rather focusing and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course pawn to a6 this is the move that
wins the game and now black realizes
whoops uh we've completely forgot about
the pawn on the queen side a7 is coming
and there really isn't all that much we
can do so black does the only thing uh
he can he goes after the h4 bishop here
but now a7 uh just attacks the rook now
comes rook to f8 we are saying okay you
bring a queen into the game queen
captures an f2 secures us at least a
draw
but there is something that white can do
to prevent this uh it looks like a
completely crazy position and might be
the one that i choose for for the
thumbnail could choose another one we'll
see what happens uh but
uh it seems that if only you can defend
the f2 pawn then you have two connected
uh two uh connected pass pawns that are
ready to become queens uh white is
completely winning this so instead of
worrying just queen the e6 check king to
h8 and queen to e3 we offer a queen
trade and next we will bring a queen
into the game so of course black cannot
allow this queen to be for is played now
hoping that the white brings the queen
into the game with pawn to b8 then we
can at least give our rook away for the
two past pawns uh but of course um
that nakano plays uh queen to a8 uh
uh who with a promotion to a queen ponte
8 with a promotion to a queen and now
what do you play here uh well d4
attacking the white queen here but they
just queen to f4 and it was in this
position on move 36 uh that um adam
fawzi resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh you
cannot capture the queen even if you
could that wouldn't really do you all
that much uh good because uh well
uh white we will just bring another
queen into the game but the rook
actually cannot move and the only other
option you have is to maybe play king to
g8 nothing else real it really works uh
but now you can see that we are covering
that v8 square many times
and now we're just going to bring a
queen into the game our third queen into
the game and now once uh this capture
fest begins queen captures queen
captures queen captures uh that's just
it white is a white has a queen black
doesn't we can even bring another one
into the game and win the game very
easily uh so yeah after queen to f4 uh
uh fawzi resigned and a beautiful
victory for kantola nakanon uh in round
five of this very prestigious tournament
so you can see that uh it all it all
started with this bishop to c5 he could
have gone for that droish line uh but he
just wanted more and it's incredible how
this past pawn not only survived for so
long uh but that he was also accompanied
by the b pawn and this all was made
possible by the advancement of the pawn
to b4 pawn to be for captures on a5 a7
a6 a7 and the rest is history so you can
see how seemingly out of nothing uh you
know black just resigns
yeah uh wonderful game thank you once
again for recommending it uh i would
like to wish a very happy birthday to
cato arbole and i would like to wish a
happy um five factorial slash two
birthday to mike from bridget mike also
fell a little bit ill so i'm uh wishing
you a speedy recovery so you can uh
enjoy uh the videos and get back to your
to your busy life i imagine uh and i
would like to thank odoltechnica benitsa
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day